Chou.
Fleur.
Ok, je commence.
Je choisis Marina.
Quoi ? C'est quoi ce rire ?
Non il n'y a rien.
Non je croyais que tu ne pouvais pas la blairer.
Mais apparement ça a changé.
Il a dit quoi ?
Il dit rien du tout.
Alors, à toi !
Ben dans ce cas, je vais prendre .... Pierrick.
Et toi Pierrick, c'est un collègue de taff ?
Ouais je ... T'es peut-être pas au courant.
La soirée du 31 on a passé un super moment, du coup, je le prends avec moi.
Et bah dans ce cas je ... je vais prendre Aurélien.
Non, t'es sérieuse ?
Même question, ouais t'es sérieuse là ?
Aurel c'est mon pote d'enfance, tu voulais jamais qu'il vienne à l'appart et là maintenant tu le prends dans ton équipe ?
Ecoute, j'ai mes raisons.
Juste pour me faire chier, quoi !
Ouais !
Ca c'est la première de mes raisons, oui.
T'es vraiment pas sympa.
C'est moi qui suis pas sympa ?
Ah c'est marrant, parce que je pensais que c'était larguer sa meuf la veille de son anniversaire qu'était pas sympa !
J'avais oublié que c'était ton anniversaire !
Tu sais gros, moi ça fait 20 piges qu'il oublie mon anniv, mais ça reste mon pote.
Sinon Bastien, vous pouvez me choisir moi ?
Oui oui, mais plus tard Monsieur Tilleul.
On est quand même bons copains !
Oui enfin, on est surtout bons voisins.
Tu ... Tu fais quoi là Papa ?
Bah je sais pas, je me disais qu'on pourrait se refaire quelques petites soirées Ligues des Champions ?
Ouais.
On se marrait bien quoi hein.
Papa, tu reviens !
Ok bah dans ce cas, moi, je récupère mon pote.
Yessaï !
Un poto !
Et alors je récupère ton style.
Performe...
Quoi ?
Quand on s'est rencontré, tu te fringuais chez Goéland Bastien, tu récupères ton pote, je récupère ton style.
Hé man !
Idée de ouf ! Là je te vois comme ça, on devrait refaire notre groupe de Ska !
Babylone, Babylone !
Désolée, je suis en retard.
Vous avez déjà commencé ?
Qu'est ce qu'elle fout là, elle ?
Et bah, j'ai appris que vous jouiez plus ensemble, donc je me suis dis que c'était le bon moment pour faire mon comeback.
Dis donc t'as pas changé toi hein.
Tain gros, elle est toujours aussi bonne hein.
Ouais, moi je pense qu'on devrait la prendre dans notre équipe hein.
Oh Papa !
Mais allez, je veux jouer avec eux moi !
Mais non, tu reviens ici !
Désolé, fréro.
Je peux peut-être venir avec monsieur ?
Ou alors, tu sais ce que je vais faire Louise ? Je vais prendre Emma et je vais la mettre sur le banc des remplaçants.
Tu fais ce que tu veux Bastien, je m'en fous.
Ok ?
Attends, ça va, te braque pas ! Est ce que j'ai dit quelque chose moi quand Etienne il a voulu intégrer ton équipe ?
Et c'est quoi le rapport avec Etienne ?
Mais regarde-le ! Regarde sa tête là, il veut jouer avec toi depuis le début !
Pas du tout non non, moi je suis là parce qu'on m'a appelé mais il n'y a pas de ...
Ouais super, depuis le début je te dis que c'est une planche pourrie ce mec.
Hé gros, t'as dis quoi là ?
Non mais, tu me le dis, une bolas dans sa gueule et c'est terminé.
T'as des bolas ?
J'ai toujours pas d'équipe !
S'il faut, moi je le défonce ton mec, ok ? Moi je vais à la salle, je suis super baraque.
Si il y a baston général, je ne me battrais pas contre la demoiselle qui est là.
Parce que je la trouve très jolie !
Ah ouais, donc toi t'es en roue libre totale, quoi ! Tu dragues devant ta fille, il n'y a rien qui te choque ?
Je ne drague pas !!
Je complimente.
Si il complimente, ça va non ?
Vous m'ignorez complètement en fait.
Non mais c'est très gentil monsieur mais en fait j'ai une règle, je ne couche pas avec le père de l'ex de mon ex.
C'est très spécifique ça.
Bon stop ! Ok, c'était pas une bonne idée en fait.
Si, tu sais quoi, on va le faire ce match !
On va jouer maintenant.
C'est pas parce que t'as perdu quelqu'un dans ta vie...
C'est un connard ce mec, connard !
Et surtout les filles ahah !
Les mecs maintenant c'est fini...
On en a ras la casquette...
Par exemple, des mecs dispo, il y a moi...
On les aime bien, malgré tout.
Et puis, je suis mieux gaulé à mon avis, je vais à la salle et ça paye.
Man, t'oublies pas hein ! C'est une connasse !
Babylone la meuf.
Oh elle t'entend la !
C'est une connasse.
J'aurais dû le laisser dans ton équipe.
Non, mais moi ça me fait plaisir de revoir la formation des Zion 88.
Tu te souviens du nom du groupe ?
Je me souviens même de la chanson que tu m'avais écrite.
Ah ouais ?
Ouais c'était ... Bah c'étaient les débuts quoi, c'était pas ...
Pas ouf.
Ouais nan c'était pas ouf ... C'était clairement pas ouf mais ...
Et ... tu crois pas que ça va nous faire bizarre de ... de rejouer après tant d'années ?
On va essayer.
Bon match !
Allez !
Hé, il a un keffieh le mec.
Ouais dessus, dessus, dessus.